[Aplausos]
pues hoy yo vengo a hablarles de
finanzas pero que no se me asusten no se
me paren
vengo a hablarles de finanzas pero una
forma distinta a lo que quizás ustedes
están acostumbrados a escuchar de
finanzas no vengo a hablarles de pesos
billetes tasas de interés de inflación
no vengo a hablarles de nada de eso
por el contrario yo creo que las
finanzas son mucho más profundas que eso
y esa idea me cautivó por completo tanto
a convertirse en una pasión de vida
afuera del círculo de lava entonces no
me voy a mover de aquí
voy a empezar con una historia
para que me entiendan un poquito más
como las finanzas otra vez son más que
pesos y billetes son una herramienta que
ustedes pueden utilizar para alcanzar
cualquiera que sean sus objetivos y no
no me refiero a simplemente tener dinero
para poder alcanzar tus sueños me
refiero a que los conceptos financieros
van mucho más profundos que es
prioritario guática cuando yo era chico
yo quería un civil
a los que se acuerden de estos
artefactos extraños los sijs costaban
alrededor de 100 pesos 200 pesos más o
menos yo era muy fan de un grupo que se
llama core
hay varias risas ustedes les gusta con
un grupo de rock corte a quien se sigan
tocando pero yo era fan del con
llego con mi mamá y le pido 100 pesos
para comprar el sitio de col
y me dice ma lo que tienes que hacer es
lavar los baños de la casa excelente me
pongo a lavar los baños la casa regreso
en mis papás ya no estaban
llegó con mi hermano y me dice ten aquí
están tus 50 pero sin qué
no sé si mi hermano se robó en los otros
50 o nada más me habían dejado 50 pero
bueno llegó a la tienda
y por sentir toalla conozcan
llegó agarro incide con sorpresa siempre
me empiezo a ir un poco triste
decepcionado y una persona me dice a
dónde vas yo digo no tengo dinero en los
50 pesos no me alcance en cie cuando me
dice por qué no compras el disco de los
black eyed peas que está el 50 por
ciento de descuento
desde los primeros y es black eyed peas
que existen
se lo vendes a un amigo porque todos
saben que cuestan 50 pesos eso hice
compré este se lo vendí
esta es la primera lección de negocios
que alguien me dio en la vida compra
barato y vende
compra barato y vender caro después
recibir mi primer sueldo cuando crecí y
adivinen qué hice con mi primer sueldo
me lo gasté todito
en el nuevo iphone
porque todos tenían un iphone y yo
quería un iphone
me lo robaron a la semana estuve
incomunicado todo un mes no se rían no
sean gachos y hasta que me volvieron a
pagar puede comprar uno un poquito más
barato para ahora sin poderme comunicar
pero me di cuenta de una cosa el morís
que quería el cedecón y el morís que
compró el iphone eran exactamente la
misma persona y tenían exactamente metas
financieras solamente que eran más eran
distintas
una era compra un cd y ahora me di
cuenta que quería viajar por el mundo
que quería comprar mi primera casa que
quería fundar una empresa que quería
formar una familia eran metas igual
y me di cuenta de tres cosas también
la vida es una serie de metas objetivos
que vamos alcanzando nuestra vida no las
vamos planteando formar un movimiento
hay que empezar una causa en el méxico
que tanto nos necesita
2 necesitas sí o sí entender la dinámica
del dinero y cuál era la dinámica el
dinero saberlo ganar saberlo gastar
saberlo administrar y saberlo
multiplicar
y entender la dinámica del dinero para
alcanzar mis objetivos
y por último me di cuenta una tercera
cosa no había don pepe ya un pp me
refiero gente que te ayude en esta
misión
en mexico para meterlos horita un
poquito en contexto méxico es un país al
igual que muchos países en el mundo con
una falta tremenda de educación
financiera las cifras dicen que siete de
cada diez mexicanos tienen problemas
financieros siete de cada diez no
ahorran para el retiro para nosotros los
jóvenes que estamos aquí el retiro
prácticamente ya no existe
ahora estamos expensas de lo que
nosotros hagamos con nuestro dinero y
como invirtamos a nuestro patrimonio qué
problemón
y no hay don pepe y para alcanzar tus
objetivos en la vida necesitas finanzas
como puede ser que nadie te ayude a esto
así que decidí empezar una aventura
y una aventura de esas veces cuando se
junta el hambre con las ganas de comer
encuentras tu propósito de vida
le dije un día
formar la cultura
imagínate que puede aportarle a la gente
que sube mis grandes pasiones hacer
crecer la vida a los demás pero una
forma tangible en mejorar la vida de los
demás
imagínate que impacte directamente a su
bienestar son lamenta ayudándolos a
tomar una mejor decisión financiera
mientras me escuchas ahorita no te
sientes muy cómodamente cómo estás
ahorita quiero más bien que pienses
hagas autorreflexión mientras me estás
escuchando y aunque te preguntes cuál es
tu causa porque hoy gracias a las
finanzas te voy a ayudar a que la puedas
alcanzar pero eso sí
no te prometo fórmulas mágicas y no te
prometo soluciones rápidas
porque nosotros los millennials también
estamos acostumbrados a querer todo en
el momento cuando lo queremos y cómo lo
queremos pero hemos olvidado un
fundamento esencial que es el arrastrar
el lápiz son los procesos es la
consistencia y todas estas tres palabras
son
final señorita van a ver por qué
así que me plantea este objetivo
imagínate que me escuchara un millón de
personas imagínate que un millón de
personas me pudieran escuchar sobre lo
que les digo que es hizo en su dinero
sobre la importancia de planear para el
largo plazo de invertir y hacer crecer
patrimonio imagínate eso
cambiar un millón de hábitos al
principio sonaba
asquerosamente imposible imagínate hace
20 años era prácticamente imposible
imagínate cuál es el impacto que tú
quieres generar cuántas vidas quieres
tocar
así que
como lo voy a lograr
excepto financieros que para mí es el
concepto financiero más importante de
todos
porque creo yo que es el concepto
financiero más importante porque tiene
impacto en las finanzas pero tiene
impacto en la vida en general
en todo lo que haces en tu día a día en
la dinámica para lograr objetivos
se utiliza el interés compuesto quiero
preguntarte ahorita antes de entrar en
temas técnica
fue la última vez que hiciste por un año
consistentemente todos los días
además de comer y dormir
para los que estén un poquito perdidos
sobre el interés compuesto ahorita se
los voy a explicar lo que pasa es que
estoy tan enojado de que en la vida se
le han pasado hablándonos de piense en
grande vea tus grandes ídolos lo que han
logrado quien quiere ser de grande te la
pasan diciendo te eso y no estoy
diciendo que esté mal
pero lo que estoy diciendo es que se nos
olvida pensar en chico
y yo hoy vengo a decirles que piensen en
chicos
para volver a sus clases va a negar con
sus maestros luego si no morir me dijo
que pensar en chino
yo hoy les vengo a decir que piensen en
chico
a los que no entienden cómo funciona el
interés compuesto se los voy a explicar
y esta es la definición
la definición financiera del interés
compuesto pero en el interés compuesto
en méxico lo conocemos desgraciadamente
del lado de las deudas qué pasa si tú
tienes una tarjeta de crédito generas
una deuda no la pagas qué pasa se
generan
y qué pasa hacia el segundo mes tampoco
lo pagas se genera intereses sobre
intereses y es una bola de nieve que se
está haciendo cada vez más grande sí o
no la gente cuando le hablo del interés
compuesto se asustan
por es que el interés compuesto también
tiene un punto positivo
explicar aquí hay una comparación del
interés simple y el interés compuesto en
una inversión imaginemos 10% anual
con el interés simple yo invierto 100
pesos y el primer año voy a obtener 10
pesos de rendimiento el segundo año 10
pesos y el tercer año 10 pesos porque el
rendimiento siempre es sobre los 100
pesos iniciales como se ve una inversión
compuesta así yo invierto 100 pesos el
primer año me va a dar 10 pesos de
rendimiento y el segundo año ya no me va
a dar 10 porque ya no estoy invirtiendo
solamente los 100 estoy invirtiendo los
más los diez y el tercer año ya no va a
invertir solamente los 100 o invertir
los 100 los 10 los y los 11 lo que me a
un rendimiento del 12.1
pero no se ve tan atractivo en solamente
12 pesos de diferencia
y así empieza
como pueden ver
esa es la diferencia al principio la
diferencia es mínima es marginal pero
conforme seguimos avanzando los
resultados se hacen exponenciales el
problema otra vez es que estamos
acostumbrados a ver los casos de éxito
donde están allá arriba en la gráfica
pero perdemos de vista el día a día el
trabajo duro todos los días
comprometerte a ser un por ciento mejor
y sobre todo la palabra que con la que
se quiere quiero que se queden hoy
además de interés compuesto es
consistencia porque en la vida no es
difícil tener éxito una vez lo que es
difícil es mantenerte
en los negocios en los proyectos en la
vida en general
esta dinámica esta gráfica que ven aquí
no tiene que ver nada cover
no tiene nada que ver con finanzas
es la vida
así que les voy a practicar yo mi
historia de interés compuesto
se acuerdan que les había dicho que
quería transformar la cultura financiera
en méxico y que quería empezar a
empoderar un millón de personas
sainz cómo empieza mi curva de interés
compuesto
plantéate un objetivo para que quieres
ahorrar cuál es el objetivo una casa tus
vacaciones lo que sea ahora 2
elimina el gasto se me gasto hornilla
que es el gasto al estar buscando
el gasto semilla
gracias por está risa es
ese primer vídeo es como inicia mi curva
de interés compuesto no fue perfecto la
iluminación está mala ni siquiera tengo
micrófono es la cámara de mi computadora
y así empezó
después sabías que en méxico alrededor
del 80% de las personas no ahora lo hace
de forma informal el tema es que hay
veces vamos el ahorro como algo que nos
dictaron nuestros padres es algo que nos
quiere imponer el gobierno pero yo tenía
un mal o raro gasto en lo que quiero
disfruto la vida igual presente que pasó
cuando quieras comprar su primera casa
el primer carro te vas a endeudar qué
pasa cuando quieras invertir oa ser
económicamente dependiente en toda tu
vida cuando te retires o qué vas a
trabajar toda tu vida o si pasa algún
imprevisto
[Música]
te vieron diferente
ya le metí animación citas ya me bañé
ya le metió un poquito de audio
ese fue el tercer vídeo
después de eso me hablaron de un banco
la tarjeta de crédito sacarla o no
sacarla
habló el banco para ofrecerte una
tarjeta de crédito y no está seguro de
tramitarla aquí te van tres cosas que es
tomar en cuenta antes de sacar tu
primera tarjeta de crédito
sólo unos meses después de haber
empezado me invitó un banco a colaborar
con ellos ese mismo banco me llevó a una
gira por méxico para dar algunas
conferencias
a gente sobre finanzas personales
y algunos talleres el señor con nosotros
hoy es un martes especial se nota en tu
rostro y se nota
desde que empecé este movimiento ocasión
financiera les quiero revelar que la
pregunta que más recibida de parte de la
gente en todos en todos mis foros
siempre era maurice cómo le hago para
tomar una decisión de inversión en que
me conviene invertir
y después saqué mi libro que es
justamente lo que estaba presente
televisa en las mañanas los martes
pero quiero que vean algo aquí
se acuerdan de ese primer vídeo ese
primer vídeo quiero que ustedes se
pregunten cómo se ve su primer vídeo de
lo que sea que quieran hacer en su vida
de su movimiento de su emprendimiento de
su proyecto de vida lo que sea cómo se
ve su primer vídeo y olvídense que sea
perfecto
lo importante es empezar la dinámica del
interés compuesto de comprometerte todos
los días ser un por ciento mejor e ir
mejorando este concepto el concepto del
interés compuesto es tan olvidado y la
verdad es que no lo valoramos como tal
les quiero enseñar esta personita una de
las personas que más admiro warren
buffett este su curva de riqueza
que ven ahí una curva de interés
compuesto
tres puntos en los que yo resumiría el
interés compuesto 1 consistencia y te
quiero invitar hoy a que seas
consistente en todo lo que hagas en tu
vida en tus proyectos de vida no además
no nada más profesionales también en tu
vida cuando te decides a desarrollar un
hábito
1 % más cómo te vas a ver después de un
año es el de importancia el interés
compuesto 2 disciplina no hay no hay
consistencia sin disciplina y 31 por
ciento mejor todos los días así que hoy
les quiero invitar 5 cosas muy rápidas
de tarea número 1 encuentra tu causa
estamos jóvenes estamos chavos todavía
tenemos mucho por recorrer nuestro país
necesita gente que esté comprometido con
diferentes causas mi trinchera son las
finanzas cuál es la tuya cómo estás
transformando nuestro país nosotros los
universitarios tenemos una hipoteca
social importante en todo la otra
cantidad de gente que no tienen las
oportunidades que nosotros tenemos no
nos podemos dar el lujo de no tomar una
causa y transformar
nuestro país
2 encuentra tus dones a mí me hubiera
encantado que cuando se hubiera estado
en la universidad no hubieran dicho esto
encuentra tus dones si tú no los has
encontrado salte de tu zona de confort y
prueba cosas nuevas
yo encontré mi don cuando me atreví a
hacer cosas nuevas cuando me invitaron a
grabar un comercial por primera vez me
di cuenta que era bueno hablando
si no hubiera ido si no me hubiera
atrevido hoy quizás su vida está en una
silla golpeando el techo preguntándome
para qué soy bueno
pero me atreví atrévanse a hacer cosas
nuevas para que encuentren sus dones 3
apoyen se una tecnología exponencial el
interés compuesto funciona un por ciento
mejor con los días pero si te apoyas de
una tecnología exponencial como son las
redes sociales el internet de las cosas
la inteligencia artificial la realidad
aumentada apóyate que esto es lo que va
a crecer para adelante si empiezas hoy
en un año le vas a estar ganando la
carrera a los demás cuatro utiliza el
interés compuesto 5 se me olvidó 5
comprométete construye tu vida y sobre
todo ayuda a construir la vida de los
demás muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]